throughout this series a lot of what
we've shown you
has been focused on the bigquery console
but when you have large amounts of data
or stakeholders manually running jobs
and creating resources
won't be very scalable in today's video
we're going to take a tour of the
bigquery apis
so that you can get started creating
programmatic data workflows
[Music]
the first api we'll discuss is bigquery
v2
which is really the core of bigquery
here you can manage data warehousing
resources like
data sets tables and routines you can
also manage machine learning models
as well as execution resources or jobs
like most of the apis we'll discuss
today you can interact with the bigquery
api
through the various client libraries
that we have available
i'm personally a python fan so having
the python library makes it so much
easier for me
to programmatically interact with
bigquery
okay so when might you want to actually
use this api well
first off you may want to
programmatically get answers to business
questions
using data that you have in bigquery
let's say every week you want each sales
team's revenue to be added to a slide
deck
so it can be presented at your company's
all hands
well in a google apps script you can
write some javascript
that loops through each of the team
names and uses them
as inputs for a parameterized query that
sums up their total revenue
we can use this information to populate
each team's slide
saving our analysts lots of time copying
and pasting
into the deck alternatively you might
want to use this api to add some new
data
into your tables for example maybe you
have
information about your customers stored
in your application's cloud sql database
you have your customer addresses but you
really want to convert them
into lat long coordinates so you can
leverage bigquery's awesome geospatial
capabilities
well in this case you can create a
google cloud function
that runs each night and grabs the new
transactions
from the database using an external
query
then uses the google maps geocoding api
to grab customer coordinates like i'm
showing in this jupiter notebook
finally you'll create and run a load job
that appends the new data to your
transactions table
so cool and on the topic of
analyzing data from transactional
databases
remember a few videos ago when we talked
about connections which allow you to
write federated queries against cloud
sql
well there's an api for that too
the connections api allows you to
programmatically create
and manage connections which can be
really useful if you have
multiple databases supporting your
application
like if you're a b2b organization with
one database for each of your accounts
here you may want to write a program
that creates a new connection
as part of the customer onboarding
process
this way your brake query users have
access to the data without needing to
send a request to you
you could even weave in the google cloud
iam api
to ensure that only users who need
access to the specified accounts data
are able to leverage the connection
besides the bigquery
and the connections api what else is out
there
well we talked a bit about pushing new
data into storage
but bigquery also has a dedicated
storage api
the storage api has two components the
read client exposes
a data stream suitable for reading large
volumes of data
this includes features for parallelizing
reads
performing partial projections filtering
data
and getting precise control over
snapshot time
at google we use the snapshot api to
build out a series of hadoop connectors
that make it easy to use bigquery as
your source of truth data lake
you could also use it to build out your
own custom connector
the right client currently in preview is
a successor to the streaming mechanism
found in the bigquery v2 api
it supports more advanced write patterns
such as
exactly one semantics for more robust
streaming inserts
keep an eye out for more info on this
coming soon
continuing on the topic of ingesting
data into bigquery
we also have the data transfer api
bigquery data transfer service allows
you to automate work
to ingest data from known sources like
cloud storage
google marketing platform youtube and
lots of other third-party data sources
on a scheduled basis with the api
you can do things like programmatically
check credentials trigger a manual
run of the transfer or get the responses
from previous transfers
now we can't have a discussion about
bigquery apis
without mentioning the reservation api
which allows you to manage reservations
and assignments
like we discussed in one of our earlier
videos
this is super useful for programmatic
workload management
let's say the dashboard for your ceo
needs to be run
every morning at 8 am well you want it
to be super fast
so you better make sure the project it
runs in will have access to enough slots
with the reservation python sdk you can
write a program that runs each morning
and creates a new slot reservation
by specifying the reservation id and how
many slots it contains
next you'll assign the reservation to
the designated bi project
where the dashboard queries run and
specify that this assignment is for
query jobs
finally you can delete the assignment
and reservation
so that slots are released back to the
organization
the last api i'll mention is one of my
favorites
data q a which is currently in preview
are business users at your organization
always pinging you to query data on
their behalf
well with a q a api you can convert
natural language text inquiries
into sql meaning you can build a super
powerful chat bot
that fulfills those query requests or
even give your business users
access to connected sheets so they can
ask analytics questions
directly in a spreadsheet wow that's a
lot of different apis
all under the bigquery umbrella and we
didn't even talk through
other related products like data catalog
but don't worry
we talked about programmatic data
governance last week
so make sure to check it out as always
thanks for joining us for bigquery
spotlight and make sure to look through
the links below for details on what we
discussed today
and code samples for the various apis
and remember stay curious
you